Andrew sorry for uh making you wait in
the studio but I'm sure you were
watching that game as well first of all
congratulations this is your first
victory at the USS championships um and
it couldn't come in a sweeter way just
an incredible final finishing touches
with that brilliant attack tell us a bit
about that your emotions right
now thanks yeah I mean going into the
tournament my goal is to get at least
one win so I'm just relieved that I man
too near the end of the tournament and I
mean yeah as you said it was just such a
sweet way to do it that's probably like
the nicest combination I've ever gotten
to play over the board so just really
really happy about it absolutely and
let's review that because it was so uh
beautiful it was at this point all the
way towards the end where you finally
realized that and it this was by the way
not an easy game it was back and forth
sure you had a better position but he
was making things very difficult for you
and finally you uh found this beautiful
ideas after Rook to C3 setting up this
Checkmate and then he thought that he's
going to uh trade the Queens off and go
into a rook end game which is probably
going to be a draw at this first of all
when did you spot this idea with Rook to
C6 that came after Rook to h8 and Rook
to C6 how many moves ago yeah yeah I saw
after well when I was playing Rick I had
to make sure that it was working but I
actually saw the idea by then so I was
just like really really having to check
like five times because there are so
many things that can go wrong but yeah
after um I mean rier I have to be 100%
sure otherwise he's just trading the
Queens yeah right uh but yeah I mean
yeah it's just crazy every single piece
on the board is used in this mating
attack absolutely the geometry is is so
beautiful because he cannot cover he
would love to cover with the Rook on F7
he loses the queen everything works in
your favor
and you did finally get it on the board
get the win on the board congratulations
Andrew tell us about your assessment of
this Championship with one round to go
this is the first time you're
participating at the USS championships
tell us a bit about your
experience yeah I'd say it's been a
success um definitely started a bit
slowly cuz I haven't been playing or
working much on chess these days so uh I
needed a warmup for sure but yeah I'm
pretty happy with the way I've played
it's just that my openings are really
not up to par with the rest of the field
as I'm not a professional and everybody
else has just really solid opening so I
just I've been just trying to get games
and this game I managed to outplay them
but and
after Sweet Victory I'm sure you want to
give some shout outs uh to the people
that have been supporting you throughout
the event would you like to do that sure
yeah I'd like to thank my coach Nicole
mitkov for helping me throughout the
tournament even though I haven't had
much time to work on chess I'd like to
thank everybody watching uh the people
in my Discord as well for playing video
games with me after after each round and
yeah well thank you very much Andrew now
I want to ask Yer a question yeser do
you know what the Discord is yeah I I I
have some knowledge but I'm not a
Discord fan myself on Andrew's Discord
Andrew if you want to invite me uh to
your uh group you know I'm
terrible video games but uh
congratulations Andrew serious seriously
we like the geometry and we saw one
Checkmate where your Rook was actually
on
h8 where uh you had uh a queen G5
Checkmate which we we we thought was
really sweet right here uh you know if
your coach asked you yeah if your coach
asked you why did you put your Rook on
h8 you could show him this variation uh
congratulations a very very nice very
very
uh picturesque finish yeah we were
talking about brilliancy prizes for
games this will be definitely one of the
candidates absolutely congratulations
Andrew thanks absolutely and where do we
stand uh